you
I'm your - Jerry this is a cool puzzle
that I came across recently that I
wanted to share with you to me it's the
coolest puzzle I've ever seen I will see
what you think about it it's white to
move if you like to go and try and solve
it go ahead pause the video see if you
can figure this one out okay some things
to note black is quite limited
should it be black smooth right here
there's only one legal move d3 this is
important if we start out by promoting
our pawn to a queen after d3 blacks only
legal move doesn't matter where we now
go with our queen the end result will be
stalemate pick your favorite square to
go with the Queen it doesn't matter it's
now a stalemate
this games a tie to draw so we need to
be something we need to do something
else correct first move is to promote to
a night and after d3 now take the pawn
yet again that would be stalemate but
rather Knight b6 this gives black a move
pawn takes Knight c7 b5 c8 and similar
to when we promote it on a8 if we
promote to a queen after b4 no matter
what we do on the white side this will
be stalemate and well if you don't want
it to be stalemate on the next turn
you'd have to do something like this or
this right here but in both cases it
would now be black who's winning
so what we need to do as Y is yet again
promote to a night and after b4 play
Knight d6 are you seeing the pattern
here we're promoting to a knight
allowing black another legal move even D
v e8 yet again if we promote to a queen
after d4 no matter where we go with the
Queen it will be stalemate unless we
make moves like this allowing black to
go ahead and win capturing the Queen in
that case so for now a third time we
promote our pond to a knight d4
and once more we give that night right
back
pawn takes Knight g7 f5 and then finally
for a fourth time we under promote again
- and Knight and this time it results in
checkmate this was simply a puzzle that
I could not not share with you guys here
on YouTube and feel free to share what
you think about this one it's I have no
idea who composed it if you know that
information feel free to share that with
me just what an awesome puzzle really
anyhow that's all I want to share with
you and I hope you enjoyed it
take care bye
you